what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man from christopher
cantwell and initially i was going to
record this alongside uh the issue that
comes out on wednesday which is
basically the conclusion of the books of
korvax iii kind of like inclusion of
this this bit of an era but so much
happens here i kind of wanted to give it
its own video right and then we'll do a
follow-up video on wednesday with the
third part so i guess tomorrow at the
time we're recording this video maybe
thursday i'm not really sure the
important thing here is that basically
you now have iron man uh who's
essentially here on the the world ship
of galactus now again he's also
accompanied by colin remember colin is
one of the people who was on board the
the kind of plan that kind of community
that iron man was on in that little two
or three issue story arc that we covered
nothing super significant here uh but
he's here to kind of accompany him right
the living tribunal basically appeared
to iron man and was like hey man uh so
like you got to go you got to get to
this world show otherwise things are
going to pop off
so him and uh and color were teleported
here now the big question that a lot of
people have been asking and i've seen
this in the comments a lot of you guys
have been asking what's going on with
galactus at this point in time okay so
we haven't really seen at least it's not
as far as i'm aware we haven't seen
anything resolved with galactus
following the events of donnie kate's
first story arc of thor so as far as
we're aware galactus is still gone but
he's still basically out of the picture
which is one of the reasons why his
world ship was so readily accessible
that's one of the things to remember
very rarely do you ever see galactus
when he's not on his world ship that his
worship serves as much a measure of
protection as it does a transportation
device or something like that it's
basically his home the whole thing about
this is galactus with him being out of
the picture it makes it easier for
people to arrive here now whether or not
christopher cantwell ties directly into
the aftermath of thor it's something
that we're not really told here instead
it's really just kind of like this ship
is largely empty but just because
galactus is not here does not mean it's
a it's a walk in the park right remember
galactus has all kinds of safety
measures along tattoo and the first of
these come in the form of like drones
and little sort of basic security
measures that both iron man and colin
are caught in now colin is hit by one of
these one of these you know lasers and
it's not enough to kill him right but
it's enough to do a little bit of damage
to him i mean really he has his armor so
that's what protects him if it were just
him flesh and blood oh he would have
been incinerated but of course iron man
and colin working together are able to
make their way past all these different
traps and whatnot until they come across
the punisher robots now the punisher
robots i think are something that we've
never really talked about here on the
youtube channel and largely because we
never really had a reason to the
punisher robots are only ever really
an option you only ever really see them
in marvel comics when you're dealing
with the world chip of galactus but
they've been around for a long long time
they go all the way back to fantastic
four issue number 49 right like the
original galactus trilogy right they're
just one of the security measures here
now the funny thing about this is we
don't really know much about them all we
really know is that they are a form of
technology that galactus had acquired
somewhere along the line in the history
of the universe but by and large
whatever form of technology they came
from is largely believed to have been
extinct and that kind of makes sense
right when it comes to like alien races
and things like that in in marvel comics
multiple races regardless of their
technological advancements have largely
just come into existence and then died
out over the course of the billions of
years that the universe has been around
so this is just one of those little
things that galactus acquired over the
course of its time now they also have
the ability to duplicate their metallic
composition is something we're not fully
aware of but they're pretty capable
they're more than enough to go
toe-to-toe with people like iron man and
so on and so forth but of course tony
stark in a position where it's like
we've got much bigger fish to fry it's
one of these things where christopher
can't well doesn't really make them like
a throwaway thing he really presents him
as a credible threat to iron man it's
simply just we're in a rush we got stuff
to do so these things are basically
taken apart pretty quickly and then they
basically bail out now of course as one
of these things is being destroyed it
initiates a self-destruct countdown and
then just explodes right i mean one of
the things to keep in mind when it comes
to galactus world ship it's massive
right it's bigger than planets so
they're only in one little facet of it i
mean this thing goes on for quite some
time it's if you ever get a chance and
maybe we'll do a video on it i guess i
don't really know how we would do a
video on the world ship of galactus but
it is colossal in size right it's just
it's ridiculous how big it is but of
course once these threats are basically
dealt with iron man and colin kind of
make their way through the uh through
the ship itself until they basically
realize that there's another ship
inbound now initially iron man of course
hopes it's his friends right patsy
walker and jim james rhodes you know
iron man or at least war machine at this
point in time and a few other people uh
in reality it's the forces of michael
korvac now remember of course michael
korvac is trying to access the world
ship of galactus the same way he did
previously and turn himself into god
right that's really what's what's going
on here with this intention the crazy
thing is that of course a fight breaks
out between iron man and colin as well
as the forces of michael korvac and uh
and colin is destroyed quite readily
he's literally just obliterated i mean
just just totally annihilated by by
corvac which of course pisses off uh
iron man iron man attacks and actually
rips the arm off of michael korvac
because remember he's basically a robot
at this point in time and then in turn
you know iron man of course is basically
overpowered by the forces of korvac and
so following that you basically end up
having like patsy walker and you've got
james rhodes war machine all those guys
who essentially show up on the scene
just in time to save iron man from being
destroyed now one of the other things to
kind of go on here is that the forces of
korvak could have killed iron man but in
his arrogance michael korvac wanted iron
man to bear witness to him basically
becoming god one to experience the
complete depths of his failure in trying
to stop korvac and two to witness what
quarterback will do in terms of
recreating the universe recreating all
of existence and so there is a bit of a
conflict that kind of unfolds in terms
of these little pot shots and stop gap
measures of the forces of iron man to
try to prevent michael korvac and his
guys from getting to the actual energy
source of uh of galactus ship and
basically absorbing that power it's not
overly important here just kind of like
a few things here and there a few little
skirmishes the real big takeaway from
this is essentially once they reach
quarterback because he is basically just
a robot despite how capable he is they
were able to tear him apart now one
thing that did happen here is that
during his time making his way to the
world ship of galactus korvac did come
across jim hammond the original human
torch right the human torch before you
ever had johnny storm uh of course jim
hammond is an actual cyborg but using a
kind of controller disc that was created
by the controller it allowed korvac to
bring jim hammond under his control once
that disc was removed by patsy walker
once you realized it was there then
basically jim hammond turned coded
against quarterback and then is really
the only reason why they're actually
able to overcome quarterback in the
first place i mean you have like misty
knight who's shooting at them and so on
and then patsy walker's just sitting
there watching it all unfold because
what's she gonna do and so you basically
have like jim hammond and you have iron
man
that are blasting korvac with all the
energy they have which is enough to
seemingly destroy a good chunk of his
physical form right it annihilates
basically the skin off of his body and
then all that's left is his robotic form
which iron man of course punches through
the chest with the intention of
destroying him the funny thing about
this is that korvac basically plays
possum here that while iron man's kind
of like okay cool we destroyed
quarterback the day is saved and
everybody's kind of out there just sort
of like relaxing and they're like okay
we got to find a way to basically you
know get off this thing right dispose of
the body that kind of stuff so we don't
have to worry about him coming back then
suddenly korvac just jumps up and lunges
directly for the the energy source of
galactus essentially giving himself the
power cosmic and in iron man's act of
desperation he does the same thing that
he basically puts himself in there now
this is one of the biggest developments
to come out of this this story by
christopher cantwell the nature of the
power cosmic when it comes to the power
cosmic in marvel comics it's it's
largely been ambiguous right marvel's
always just kind of said it's the source
of galactus power done right and that's
basically and that's that's really all
you get one of the things that's kind of
given here sort of sort of put here is
iron man kind of having his own
recording device right for his suit says
like record everything that i'm saying
here and everything that i'm seeing he
says the power cosmic from what i
understand scientifically it's the
primary substance of omniscience
omnipresence the collapse of space and
time into a singular energy matter
manipulation the removal of boundaries
between dimensions anything and
everything essentially what what looks
like christopher cantwell is saying here
is that the power cosmic itself is
basically godhood the ability to do
anything you want to do the ability to
like leave universes right to travel
from one universe to the next to control
anything and everything in all of
existence now in reality we would have i
mean if this is this is a new definition
for the power cosmic the question we
have to ask is why didn't galactus just
use it to its full potential right why
didn't galactus travel to alternate
realities travel to other universes
right some dead universe or something
like that you know why why is it that
the power of godhood is seemingly being
used in a limited capacity by galactus
and we have we kind of have to
extrapolate an answer right to sort of
delve into the realm of hearsay and
haphazard guessing i would argue that
this is because it's the role galactus
plays the galactus is a cosmic entity
that people like eternity and people
like infinity and master order and lord
chaos and people like that oblivion and
so on they're capable of incredible
feats but you never really see them
exercising those things the reason why
is because it's not their job to and
galactus job is to basically travel
around the cosmos and consume
life-sustaining planets in order to
basically propagate his existence in
years past marvel's tried to sort of
explain this with stories like the
abraxas side and saying that if galactus
were to die he would unleash what is in
effect the representation of chaos and
destruction across the multiverse which
came in the form of abraxas wasn't a
story that people took to very well so
marwa kind of swept under the rug once
they ended it and that was it you just
never saw or heard from abraxas again
they've had stories like the trial of
reed richards where they basically
explained the role galactus plays across
the universe but then people also kind
of find themselves asking the question
if this really is basically the source
of godhood then why does a galactus just
like fill up on some source of energy
and then create a world that basically
is that he could essentially deposit all
that energy into and then take all that
energy out and just kind of live in a
sort of repeating pattern of like
consuming the energy of that world and
then giving that energy back to himself
so his power stays stagnant across the
board never increases never decreases
but he doesn't have to destroy planets
across the entirety of the cosmos if we
were to invoke the celestial's origin
which is really what marvel's doing now
they're taking the origin of the
celestials from earth x and they're
rolling it directly into uh the main
marvel universe it initially started
with jonathan hickman and shield and now
has become kind of a mainstay in kieran
gillan's eternals that galactus true
purpose is to travel around the universe
and basically destroy worlds that that
celestials would normally deposit their
quote-unquote offspring into in order to
prevent celestials from overpopulating
the universe that's the role he plays
now but that's why you don't see him
using this this level of power to its
full totality because he's simply just
not supposed to and so once iron man
basically experiences what it means to
effectively be imbued with the power
cosmic reliving his own past going
through all these different moments
confronting his failures as a person and
seeing himself as he truly is once the
process is effectively complete he's
officially bonded with the power cosmic
he goes forward not in the same capacity
that michael korvac does which is to
bend the universe to his whim to do
whatever it is that he wants with all of
existence but instead to turn the
universe into a place where seemingly he
can actually improve it right it's one
of the things that iron man says right
he's like he's like this is my time i
have so many ideas i could fix
everything starting with myself but
that's just the beginning i promise you
it would all be so beautiful this leads
to him going back and confronting
michael korvac basically appearing as
iron man being god right cosmic iron man
right the iron god if you want to call
him that whatever the case is i mean the
guy has so many names and so once this
fight and this whole conflict breaks out
what we actually end up doing is
transitioning over to what is in effect
a priest basically him living on the
planet satania which really looks more
like a space station than a tried and
true planet but whatever you want to
call it right just kind of these these
this this giant space station sitting on
a on a piece of a dead world that
basically this guy kind of chronicles
everything going on right he talks about
like draconius he talks about the cosmic
entities and all that kind of stuff and
in effect we kind of jump back right to
this point when michael korvac and iron
man were basically fighting each other
that this guy living on this world had
basically lived on a very peaceful world
right but they were also capable of
shape-shifting different things like
that this idea that they basically just
kind of wanted to be left alone and they
were never really much of a threat to
anybody unless somebody made themselves
a threat right otherwise they were
largely pacifists but that their entire
world essentially ended when the fight
between michael korvac and iron man
ended up destroying a star right setting
a star to supernova and that these
people had minutes to evacuate and the
aftermath of this star exploding because
as fast as light travels in the midst of
an explosion in space it was only a
matter of time before it annihilated
their world and so what you have here
and this is what's kind of interesting
what you have here is a battle of cosmic
proportions between iron man as god
wielding this power cosmic and michael
korvac doing the same thing now here's
the funny thing to understand about this
the way a battle like this would
actually happen it probably wouldn't
really be fought in this way right it
would likely be fought by way of
something like the astral plane or
something along those lines but marvel
depicts the fight of cosmic entities by
having like worlds destroyed basically
like a street fight as if the street
fight took place and the battleground
was the was the entire universe in order
to illustrate the gravity of the power
these guys have and and one of the funny
things about this this all started with
jim starlin that it wasn't always done
this way but when jim stalin wrote
infinity gauntlet and the only real way
to depict the massive scale of the
battle that was taking place was for
like celestials to throw planets at
thanos in an effort to defeat him when
he had the infinity gauntlet it became a
mainstay of marvel comics and that's the
reason why and while you did kind of see
that beforehand a little bit that's the
reason why post infinity gauntlet when
you see a massive battle like this
between two godly beings that planets
are just caught in the crossfire stars
different things like that it's designed
to illustrate how massive this is right
i mean there's literally a point when
iron man gets the upper hand on michael
corback and michael korvac takes a
moment to rest by sitting on a planet
right or by by kind of like laying on an
entire planet it's just it's designed to
illustrate the gravity of it all it's
really the best you can do in the world
of comics and it's one of those funny
things because the battle between them
is as much philosophical as it is
literal right in the sense that iron
man's like you have a small perspective
michael korvac your goal is to basically
conquer the universe and then turn it
into how you believe the universe should
function i have bigger ideas i've got
grander plants there's much better
things that we can do and so what's kind
of interesting here is that when that
star is destroyed and ultimately ends up
wiping out the planet of of draconius
that iron man actually comments on it it
was like do you even feel what it was
that you just did you annihilated a star
which wiped out basically the entire
solar system right and and the response
of quarterback is a necessary sacrifice
to stop your interference and that's
kind of the funny thing because it is
right i mean if you know most people i
imagine would look at this from the
perspective of oh my god he just
destroyed that entire star and now those
people are dead right but when you're
wheeling the power cosmic you can you
can basically reconstitute the star and
resurrect those people from the dead so
are they really dead in the first place
right it's one of those kind of moral
philosophical quandaries if you have the
ability to resurrect a dead person back
to life in their original state before
they were ever killed was it morally
wrong to kill them in the first place i
mean it's one of those weird little
quagmires that you kind of find yourself
dealing with whenever you're looking at
stories and comics one of the many
reasons why i love comics so much but
the whole idea of iron man is i don't
intend to wipe out entire civilizations
in order to make the universe better we
don't really know what his motivation is
or at least how his plan would unfold we
simply just know that he doesn't really
want to destroy things or even just like
recreate all existence in the same
capacity michael korvac does and so
realizing that this fight within this
universe would lead to just massive
calamities and all levels of destruction
this basically leads to iron man
creating a portal to another reality to
another universe and sending michael
korvac through the funny thing is that
once he sends them into this universe we
don't really get an explanation of what
universe this is we're just told it's a
dead universe where seemingly everything
in this universe was destroyed we don't
know how it happened we don't really
even know why it happened we simply just
know that it did this is not the cancer
verse right if this were the cancer
verse it would be filled to the brim
with life right i would just it would
just be ships everywhere and all kinds
of stuff the mini angled ones would
probably immediately seize on uh on
michael korvac and iron man and just
subjugate them and in truth despite the
power cosmic that they have they really
wouldn't be able to stand much of a
chance against those guys i mean
galactus in that universe had the power
cosmic and he was destroyed they
literally turned him into the galactus
engine those guys who don't know what
i'm talking about thanos imperative was
a ridiculously great story where like
they turned galactus into a machine like
into a just into what's basically just a
giant cosmic gun it's crazy
it's absolutely nuts but with this guy
you know of course i'm kind of telling
this this story in the past tense with
him basically observing right this piece
observing this fight between michael
korvac and uh and and iron man the fight
is just colossal and scale right huge
amounts of energy being let off and then
in a moment when michael korvac is just
kind of temporarily knocked out or
however you want to see it when it's a
bit of a reprieve iron man realizes
they're in a section or they're in the
the saul system right like the milky way
galaxy and he sees earth that earth
looks like it was basically just
destroyed right i mean it's not really
destroyed in the physical sense just
like devoid of life and he realizes that
like that's a fate that could
potentially befall the world because of
humanity's own actions or an alien
invasion or something like that and he's
like i will help my universe right i
will help my universe become better than
it has been and so when michael korvac
goes on the attack the response of iron
man is i'm sorry corvac it's my turn now
and just bam just like attacks this guy
and he doesn't necessarily destroy him
or at least it may seem like he kind of
destroys him but what it does is it
basically meets with the arrival of the
cosmic entities now here's the thing
right it's the cosmic entities sure like
eternity and in death and like you know
sire hate and mistress love and like the
in-betweener and infinity all that kind
of stuff the big thing here is oblivion
and the living tribunal show up here and
it's kind of like like literally the
tribunal is like this battle ceases now
right this battle ends now right this is
this is done right this whole thing is
finished like you have disturbed the
natural balance of things michael korvak
you have seized a power that does not
belong to you and elevated yourself to
godhood you will come with us now here's
the funny thing about this is that could
the tribunal particularly have involved
himself at any point in time sure right
the power of the living tribunal trumps
the power of of the the power cosmic or
at least it seemed to be that way right
maybe that's not the case anymore right
it looks like christopher cantwell's
kind of toying with the the cosmic
hierarchy in marvel comics right that a
wielder of the power cosmic is basically
a person who wields the power to do
anything and everything with no limit to
the things they can or cannot do right
when you're dealing with cosmic entities
sure they can do a whole lot of stuff
but eternity's power is limited to the
universe that he represents he can't
alter a different universe because he's
the physical manifestation of the
universe it's like the color red being
able to change the color blue unless you
mix the two together it's not gonna
happen they're just two distinctly
different colors but the important thing
is that uh is that the cosmic entities
basically step in and they're like we're
done right they ultimately end up taking
a michael korvik away now the question
that's asked here really comes by way of
master order when he says like what do
we do with iron man right this guy has
been imbued with the power of the cosmos
itself like he could open portals to
other other realities the guy could
basically do anything he wants to now of
course mistress love says give him trust
sire hate says give him pain and then of
course mr's death is just like kill
right you know because she's obsessed
with death and even oblivion steps in
now the funny thing about this is that
it appears that the statement of
oblivion trumps the statement of
everybody else oblivion says it matters
not what we give or do not give the path
has been set so says oblivion and so at
that point the tribunal basically steps
in and says presently your future is
clouded right but the ultimate outcome
may be satisfactory to us and so
ultimately the cosmic entities take
michael kor back away and iron man
himself basically returns to the main
marvel universe and so in the end what
you end up getting is this priest of
course again who crash lands on satania
after escaping this dead reality and and
witnessing this meeting of the cosmic
entities and so on and just kind of
recording everything that's happened
here basically kills himself so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end i'm excited to see
what issue number what the issue number
16 the issue on wednesday comes up with
i'm hyped about that but thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace
you